mais ici ne voulait pas manquer ce
rendez-vous
saisir l'occasion de transmettre son
message aux dirigeants du monde entier
sachant qu'ils sont juste à côté
les gouvernements doivent agir
maintenant et plus rapidement dit m ils
sont des milliers comme ici à demander
que la coop 26 la grande messe de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
ne se conclut pas par 2,5 ou prière
c'est la 26e conférence sur le climat et
nous n'avons pas encore vu d'action
concrète lance-t-elle parce que mais ici
à peur très peur pour son avenir jusqu'à
ce
qu'en pluie c'est pour son petit fils
qui les sortit marché
c'est important dit il c'est la seule
chance qu'on aura de notre vie de bien
faire les choses
il veut léguer à son petit homme une
planète en santé
raphaël savaria un québécois participent
comme observateur à la conférence voyez
un peu après une victoire importante
pour les actions concrètes pour lui la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
est une question de justice une justice
climatique payer initialiser n'ont pas
la chance de peut lui apparaître mais
pour avoir une économie qui prospère
donc si de reconnaître et de financer
aussi les transitions dans les autres
pays ici il veut que son premier
ministre justin trudeau comprenne que le
temps est compté qu'ils entendent la
détresse des jeunes ici chez eux et
conscience je pense que on est beaucoup
la jeunesse est anxieuse comment ces
jeunes qui se sentent au bord du
précipice était accompagné par greta
tomberg la jeune militante suédoise at
you la comen c'est encore une
célébration du statu quo lens greta
c'est honteux dit elle
[Applaudissements]
le pouvoir à la jeunesse chante cet
homme car les jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui
seront les décideurs de demain eux
prendront les choses en main ici elisa
céret radio-canada glasgow en ecosse